on this week's show how to find joint
venture partners in the news we look at
the fastest-growing cities for rent and
we're gonna be answering all your
property related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS I'm Alistair Cunningham welcome to
the property investors podcast give me
give me an interesting show yes it is I
what we're covering today is a topic
that I get asked do you know what it
must be every day I get something
message me this question how do you find
investors and how do you find you're
bent upon do you want me to stop
messaging you please yeah because it's
getting a bit tedious so yeah we've got
a good show lined up
we've also there's a news article come
out today regarding the fact that the
cities in the UK were rent is growing
the fastest and also we're rent is
decreasing the fastest as well which is
quite interesting because that office
obviously reflects on house prices and
sure so I mean because obviously if the
rent rise this yeah they're more people
wanna more investors want to buy there
and then that in turn pushes up house
prices so if you're looking to buy
somewhere with good capital appreciation
stay tuned in we're gonna be talking
about that anybody as well so before we
go any further what have you been up to
what have you been up to I notice you've
had a haircut you're looking a bit fresh
how about a haircut I had a day off okay
you know I think it's very true
sometimes so so visibly being like
hopping it's been like long day's early
in the morning yeah till late at night
day after that last week I didn't have
any a day at home okay I went home
sometimes but like at 11:00 yeah backups
is really crazy sort of the day off yeah
recharge the old batteries
I went had a haircut Oh had a massage at
the crazy bear hotel so I sound you've
had an interesting couple of days it's
nice to see you resting because we do
work incredibly hard and people maybe
see exactly they had matter of hours we
put in but we do put a supporter you
might time a time for everything that's
important so yeah all good all good so
what about today we're going to be
talking about finding joint venture
partners and raising raising finance
yeah sorry
finding joint venture partners to raise
finance find investors for deal sourcing
or for any other reason you need
investors and that's a question I get
asked loads yeah absolutely let's start
with finding a JV partner time so if you
are if you're looking to take one of
property or taken on deal or rent
terrain or anything really and you quite
haven't quite got the funds or you
haven't got the time or the experience
and potentially you're looking for
somebody to assist you with that how
would you go about finding them okay
well first of all let's say that most JV
partners I've done both I've you know
I've been sort of both sides of the coin
so you one side of the coin is you're
the you're the expert you're the one
that you're the one that knows what to
do how to find the deal yeah how to
manage the deal what depending on what
it is because most JV partners it's
maybe a bar refurbisher finance type
deal or you know so I've played that
part where you're looking for someone to
invest the money but I've also paid the
part where I've found someone else
that's the expert and I've given them
the money and then as part of the deal
as well so I've done both I think it's
important that you've got one the
problem is most people are looking for a
JV partnership most people that come to
us and say I wanna be a J I want to be I
want a JV partner they've kind of got
nothing going for them well they bring
nothing to the table do they know I
think where any sort of JV arrangement
there's got it there's got to be our
balance of what both you bring to the
table it cannot be a case of like you're
bringing absolutely nothing to the table
but you want somebody to put all the
time and all the money and all the
experience into the do because that's
not fair well normally that do me what
it is is they what they want to they
want someone else to put the money in
and they want to be the one that finds
the deal except etc but why would
someone who had money
in invest in you've got to think about
what what value that you're bringing
that way and not just the value but also
the proof of the value because that I
personally wouldn't lend money to
someone who'd not done a deal yeah
exactly I seem as if it's like this is
my first deal why would I lend you money
unless it was someone that I really
trusted yeah there's a lot of trust in
it and obviously if nothing there's got
a lot of trust but no JV agreement
should be done on a handshake it should
always be done legally through through
solicitors through the correct contracts
to create paperwork to protect both
parties so that that is from the offset
make sure you do it legally through the
solicitors and get done correctly so I
might do it for like you're like you're
like the first person not let me money
for it for a JV contract was my my
grandma I bought I've done other deals I
bought borrowed money but the first one
that was sort of like a family there was
my grandma let me money for a deal I
didn't have very much experience yeah to
be fair so she was taking a bit of a
gamble on me but she trusted me that I
would pay the money back if a nice ass
she trusted that I would paid the money
back I tell you an example I had about
three weeks ago and I had somebody
messaged me on Facebook and they were
they were talking to me about deal with
all these deals have been fined and and
lately I just got a string of messages
like ten messages and they're all deals
that they've been fined and things that
are and like we don't mind looking at
deals and things that but we're not
gonna like we get you get messages every
day I get message laws of people saying
can you have a look at this deal can you
go steal we just don't have time to know
that because we like to keep that
service for people that are on their CAD
I mean people that are that are actually
coming on to do follow training with her
so we we don't review deals for just
peel that randomly messages and this guy
kept he messaged me lots of times and I
looked at one of the deals and it was
all right it was nothing special but
then I got I ran the message or from
about a day later and it was and look I
also I really love what you've been
doing I watched your fall you all sort
of stuff I'm an aspiring investor and
can you basically invest in one of these
deals and I'll run it and I'll manage
and I'll give you like a 10% return on
your money and all the deals you were
sending we were just right move links
they were just probably as he's found
that would make a potentially a good hm
or or by refurbished refinance whatever
um but really when when I sit down and
think about it what's he bringing to the
table because you could find a deal like
that yourself I can find deals like that
I've got people that work for me that
people that can go out and do that day
in day out so what's this guy bringing
people how can he needs to differentiate
himself from everyone else if he wants
to raise a JV like listen I'll happily
invest with somebody happily I'll I
arrange to JV yesterday with somebody I
was in Wales yesterday and I arranged a
JV with with them a couple of girls and
Wales yesterday her buying in the
process of buying our commercial
residential place and we've agreed in
principle jayveer arrangement on that so
I will happily invest right but what are
the what you'd bring into the table now
this guy that messaged me all he was
bringing the table was right move links
so he's got no experience he's got no
real knowledge he won't invest in his
own education and he just wants me he
wanted me to lend him the deposit money
yeah I didn't obviously respond to this
message I responded saying Luke thanks
very much we get in touch em if you want
any more information email the company
input so I'm a little con but he's not
actually bringing much the table it was
brings right move blame but he's not
really much the table to you yeah but
but let's say he found someone so that
we're kind of Ross posed the worst
people to approach because we've got but
number one we get approached all the
time so we seen deals out I'm a number
two we've got would would be actively
buying property ourselves anyway so but
I suppose maybe maybe for example if you
had a family you think about who can you
add value to exactly so what value do
you have
what value does he have that you don't
have nothing really not really because I
can do if thing he's doing but if he
went to somebody for instance that he
knows is about a little bit of money
that it's not got any knowledge
whatsoever in the property to them is a
complete foreign beast yeah like so long
maybe got 50 grand say would like to
invest glad to get a good return on
their money and like friends and saw it
cut you off I'm sorry to cut you off
I just I was speaking to somebody
yesterday around and they go to the
business foreign foreign Network meeting
foreign and what is up for years yeah
I've never been to one but I found them
incredibly boring right now I went to
one and I didn't get much from at all
but you won't my point being is he he
goes to this event and he goes to event
every single month and he speaks at the
event for 10 minutes he does a 10 minute
picture but what he's been doing on his
property business is it for enter he'll
probably travel round I don't know what
he does I all I know is equals to them
quite regular yeah and he's now been
given opportunity to speak for like 5 or
10 minutes just about what he does in
business probably things that know the
people that are they I don't really know
much about property they very few of
them do so he's one of the the jayvees
that he's arranged it's three or four in
because they know nothing about property
he's brought them a deal they're no
funding it for him and they're getting
like they're not even getting a it's not
even that high return I think they get
something 8% return which they were very
happy with yeah but and he's that
robbing his hands together because he's
really happy with that so it's a case of
your value has to what you're bringing
to the table has to be more than what
you're asked what the person that the
opposite party is bringing was could be
a win-win so it's got it's got to be at
least equal like for instance if
somebody was to come to ours without
with an opportunity it's got to be such
a mind-blowing opportunity that we can
either possibly find it ourselves or we
we just don't have access to it and and
things that are so we like I know you do
I know I do I know Samuel certainly does
we get offers every single day for JVs
for for opportunities and we generally
only do business with Academy members in
a way because it's a park of them being
in the Academy and we do some you don't
but let's have a think that okay so
let's put ourselves in the minds of
somebody who is watching this yeah let's
learn a bit about property hmm maybe not
doing the actual deals it's got no money
yeah looking for their first deal
they're looking for a JV partners team
up with to do it what would what would
you recommend how would they do it how
would they go about finding apparel
don't look the first thing is you need
to be networking you need to be going to
as many many networking events as
possible and and when you're there don't
be just trying to sell to people because
it
you've got to add value to people before
you sell to them you've got to you've
got to have helped them in some sort of
way before you then try and sell to them
and especially like a decent investment
I mean I'm not talking about going to
like sale and somebody or a couple
hundred pound away if I'm talking about
a big investment where you're asking
them to invest and you need to need two
three things I need to know you they
need to like you need to trust you
nobody will do business with if you
don't if they don't know like and trust
you it's that simple right
so you need to go to networking events
you need to network like crazy
constantly be adding value to people
constantly be like trying to assist them
before you sort of stand up and go hey
I've got this amazing deal I'm looking
for an investor because do you know what
we've all been to these pin meetings or
whatever networking event where you get
the same people every single month stand
up and go hey my name is Joe I'm a
manager a property here hi Joe I'm a
property investor and I've got some
amazing deals I'm looking for investors
and it's just it's just so boring so yon
come on nobody's interested change your
picture change your 20-second picture
how can you add value to people so that
they actually wanna come and talk to you
then you build a relationship build that
relationship before you do anything and
then you can then start talking about
deals instead along the lines of hi I'm
actually I specialize in HMO service
combination yeah if anyone's got any
questions or looking to arrest it I'm
more than happy to sit down anyone give
you free advice on how to absolutely
because you're offering on value you're
offering them help and you're offering
to help them you're not just standing up
saying hey I'm I my name is Joe I found
this amazing deal I ain't got no money
but I found a deal can someday JV with
me it don't work like that
it just doesn't because properties about
people build relationships with people
and the money will come and yes many
people say that the the best the right
deal will always money will follow so if
you find that the onus and amazing the
old the money will fall and I think
that's generally quite true because if
team I've had an amazing the office it's
been funded or are funded or have found
ways to fund it or whatever you think to
begin with for you know they were said
the first deals always hard it is yeah
part of the reason for that is like
you've got no experience what would you
think before you do jayvees see that it
would be a good idea to have done a deal
you can show them and say yeah so for
example you write for example yeah
because you're a deal sorcerer you could
you know you don't have to even invest
in any of those deals but you can very
easily turn around to an investor and go
let me give an example of some of the
deals I promise on my clients this one
this one this one but these are the
deals these the RO is that I found this
one it's amazing I'm not someone to
invest it and it's like you immediately
get that credibility I think it's
morning that you've that you've walked
the walk before you sell it's a how
would you how would someone but it's one
of those I was I was interviewing
someone but it's been to use today for
an accountants assistant okay and it's
people that have come fresh out of uni
yeah they're a lot of them we've got
like a first one on their degree but you
know what they haven't got experienced
Syrians so they and the companies are
saying you need experience and it's like
a catch-22 because they haven't got the
experience there's no more put their
faith in them okay let me ask you this
question gone and this is a question for
everyone at home as well
would you rather employ somebody fresh
our uni that's got all the paperwork all
the the certificates that say they can
do it all but they've got no real life
experience or would you rather employ
some day and it's got twenty five year
years real-life accountancy experience
but no certificates what would you
rather employ it depends on the role for
an accountant for an accountant or an
Accounts Assistant so today your
accountant I want someone I don't care
about the experience I want someone
who's fresh really for this role yeah
for account assistant someone's gonna
come in and just learn to our way not
come in with twenty five that's actually
very interesting yeah yeah but I kind of
agree with that actually because they're
coming in with a complete blank bit of
paper like I'm freshly qualified young
I'm wrong right people pick up habits
that's a good that is a very good
analogy however if I was looking for
someone to run my accounts if I was
hiring an accountant to manage my
accounts it was someone who had two
advisers expense or fresh I'd definitely
go for the twenty five years experience
obviously with the can see they've got
to be accountants is just an example it
could be a plumber it could be a
cameraman and whatever yeah don't man
the job rules irrelevant and I think
experience always outweighs fresh
qualifications I think okay I've seen so
many people are fresher you needed but
they they couldn't like they can't tie
the bloody shoes do you not mean they
can't do the simplest of tasks I've seen
this so many times and it's just that
it's laughable so I think I think
experience all the time over over RM
qualification okay obviously when it
comes to like P an adulterer you've got
me qualified but I'm not saying I'm not
belittling qualifications I'm just
saying if I had temple if I if I had a
job role and it was for say a
videographer I would rather they have
experience in qualification because
experience will always outweigh
qualification in my opinion it might be
wrong and if it is then what's my
opinion right so it's how do you get
experience yeah when we know how do you
do that I would say deal selling would
be good yeah and we taught if you
watched we did an episode about how to
become a deal source and we and we
suggested doing your first deal for free
absolutely yeah so far so what you could
do for example is you could do a couple
of free deals where you find the deals
you go to an experienced investor you
say hey if I I'll sort you a deal for
free because then they'll check it out
for you as well and go how you've
screwed up here or whatever they'll help
you because you're asking for help but
you're doing it for free for them right
so so that they can see you putting
themself out then you've done a couple
of deals then so at least when you're
trying to raise JV you can turn around
say hey I teamed it with this person
this is the deal that I found and this
was the return on investment I'm looking
for an it the this is the new one I
found this one's even better yeah I'm
looking for at least there you got a bit
of credibility
so you actually because one thing going
on a you know learning the information
seeing your people doing its very
differently actually doing it yourself
yeah I agree with that one thing I will
say law is if you're completely fresh to
it yeah yeah don't make the stuff up
don't don't don't know what I'm saying I
know it does but we did say don't like
fake it till you make it right I don't
agree with that and so like things like
if you've not done any deals
but you're looking for JV Ponte tell
them yeah this would be your first deal
but explain somehow you've done the
calculations explain to them how you've
done your due diligence and really go to
town and make sure you do it thoroughly
and just be completely transparent and
completely honest form and I'll tell you
what most there's a lot of people would
still deal with you because it's it's a
risk and entrepreneurs are there to take
risk well it shows that you can be you
know if you're very very honest it shows
that you can be trusted
yeah 100% and it comes back to know like
and trust people deal with people in all
they can trust step form of them would
you send number one gain a little bit of
experience yeah maybe food deal sourcing
for free or something but gaining a bit
of experience to show that you obviously
get to learn how to do it first of
course and then once you once you know
how to do it get a bit of experience
doing it for free yeah under then you've
got a bit of social proof yeah network
but don't network by selling network by
adding oxide value building
relationships speak think about think
about what Valuev got yeah and then what
they need so don't approach people like
you because you don't need someone to go
find you a deal you've got that you were
a dill sauce and cumin you got that
coming at you coming out your eyebrows
but come at my eyebrows and let your
eyebrows it's like a new one private Joe
it doesn't matter but but find someone
who maybe maybe is your family member a
friend you've got some money who's keen
to invest you would like to get 8%
return on investment and then would you
okay here's a question then and then
well I think this is probably a good
thing to finish off and I've got
something what's a so I think this is
will be it okay guys so let's say that
if it's not I'm going to say afterwards
okay cool you've got a you've got a
family member yeah uncle right who you
know has got a hundred grand sighs
mm-hmm you and he's got it in a savings
account he's only 1% interest yeah yeah
and you want him to invest of you how'd
you ask him right yeah yeah you knew you
knew I was going right okay this is how
I would do it um so let's just
hypothetically say exactly that can I be
the richer uncle right okay so only
someone's rich uncle at some point I
would come on I would I was I was come
up jingle hey Tavish set your uncle's
name and how I just tried to think well
really
got its name there establish establish
McTavish Oh like a surname yeah okay
I'll tell you what hey William as in
William Wallace okay anyway right so I
would the way I would this exactly how I
would play it right I would hear from
haven't heard me in five years what can
I do for you I just thought yeah
no listen how you do that's how you do
it right just talk to them about the
deal say look I've got this amazing
property deal it's it's it's tell me
figures it's fifty thousand pounds it's
gonna need our 15,000 pound refurb once
has been refurbed we're very confident
the end value is going to be like ninety
thousand pounds and so we're going to be
able to pull a lot of our money out of
the deal this is our buyer be publicly
financed deal that we're doing we've got
teams in the area we've got people in
there that can do the work and we're
very confident we can turn that money
around an instant four to six months do
you know anybody that be interested in
that hmm so hypothetically yeah if if I
did know it was interesting it mm-hmm
how would they're meant to be protected
well they would have a force charge and
the property or they would have some
sort protection on it and typically
would be a frost charge done through the
solicitor so basically after the
mortgage you're the first person that
gets paid okay so like if it all went if
it all went badly the person might my
interested hypothetical friend yeah
would they be the one that got the house
take a secured loan do you know I mean
first charges if you if you borrowed
money from our bank and you secure it
against property it special so what
would they return about investment but
let's say at the moment they weren't in
the bank only one percent well look on
this deal these are just half the
members on this deal I'm looking to give
them tips in and whatever they lend 10%
okay so what kind of happens here is we
end up having this very hypothetical
conversation where they're asking on
behalf of themself yeah really but
acting like they're interested in in
their in their friends just remember
this you never I'm never going to ask
you for the money I'm never going to ask
you for the money but I'm gonna I'm
going to say to you and I'm going to
speak to you in a way that look I've got
this amazing deal I'm looking for an
investor do you in any of
connections any of your friends do you
know anybody that is looking to invest a
little bit money make a little bit more
return yeah of course you just gonna
casually have a conversation with them
about some of the deals you doing before
yeah what the investors have got they
are I've actually got I know who I'm
looking for investor right now do you
know anyone that might be interested in
earning eight to ten percent on their
interest rather than like the one was it
yet yeah and and you know what I would
finish on I would never say all by the
way if your interest you can do it now I
would always finish on that if you ever
hear of and without that just send in my
way let me know and then I would change
the subject completely change your
subject so like what are you up to last
week just change the subject because in
their head they're thus a limit to
themselves
yeah in the head they're like well
actually I've got money in the bank i I
wouldn't mind getting a bit return and
do you know what he's a nice guy
but even then I would still not talk
about it I would leave it a couple of
days you don't you don't want them to
feel like you're selling to them exactly
and you're pressuring them you want to
just let them know and if they're
interested they'll come to you do you
know obviously you know Antony Antony
journeys are a very successful Academy
member winner of the eviction and today
Wilma yeah and I commented John but
Antony Wilmot
yeah anyway he the reason be is this
jaundice middle name right he blocked me
calling Alastair Alastair Kia Andrea so
Antony joined Academy months ago and
he's now on thier team properties now
he's not bought long
but he's the the vol being purchased but
using JB's using lease options but none
of it has been done using his money it's
all been done to joint venture financing
every single deal so poor waters topper
anyway it's all done it's all been done
through joint venture financing yeah
every single bit of its JV finance now
that's that's that's true and he had no
knowledge he had no investors he was
working I think was being it was it
being cure scenes but I don't know
Sainsbury's looking at a big big chain
came to them they crash course came to
the Academy learnt how to find investors
letting out tonight when I learnt I have
two JV now he started he's done 13 deals
with JV money yeah and they're all
getting their all and creatively happy
with them I know some of the JB's are
avoided
paid back now they're desperate to do
more with them and it's just know like
and trust built relationships with good
people and he's a smart guy cigars good
so yeah cool no that's how you go that's
how we would recommend finding JV
investors right it's now time for this
[Music]
in the news this week we are going to be
discussing the latest article that's
come out regarding rents so on BBC news
at minute
the UK's city cities where rent is
rising the fastest so tell us why that's
important
well of course it's important because
it'd be a good place to invest if you're
looking to invest it's a sign for the
for the future what's going on in that
area
what developments are there why is why
these places go not it also
interestingly covers where's going down
and you looked I've had a little look so
you know so I can't make a guess I've
know I've read a little bit but what
have you read that noting on yeah good
Manchester Manchester's not only that I
can say okay now I can't remember it I
read only taxi and just Leeds Leeds okay
Bristol Bristol yeah fossil and the
biggest fool is in the UK is across the
whole of the UK is across the whole the
UK it's I they're going to be I don't
think it's gonna be North England hold
on hold on bear with me bear with me
right we're bearing I think it's gonna
be somewhere in Scotland of course
Glasgow no Aberdeen yes all right
yeah Aberdeen I'll tell you I I think I
know why is why the oil industry yeah
yeah oil industry is dying up there
because the the most each one of oil
next 20 years would be a lot of oil rigs
are shutting down because they've done
what they had to do the oil industry up
there is cutting jobs left right and
centre so people are moving back to
wherever they come from because the job
isn't there anymore so yeah the rents
will be going down because there's a lot
about there's a lot of supply up there
at the minute so happening is the worst
of your best ones Notting um no no it's
been a little a little Nottingham has
been a little it's been under the radar
you know and it's 5.4% creeping up but
it's under the radar nobody really talks
about nothing on the whole topic
Manchester leads but they don't talk
about them like they do and they're the
only three
the rents went to more than the average
wage so we mentioned so what's the wager
can the worst three or aberdeen which is
the worst and there's two england one in
the midlands Wolverhampton no wall sold
no
Coventry really what rents gone down on
down interesting cuz hate you more
demand is going up in Coventry and sit
on down or maybe there's this a single
this office it's not it's not it's not
gonna be hit and then northern sitter
Newcastle no but close pain and we are
that's not see reason
Newcastle Sunderland and Middlesbrough
ah good old Middlesbrough yeah nearly
3/4 whose is effectively three-quarters
of 16 to 24 year olds and almost half of
25 to 34 year olds rent from a private
landlord okay so in the bay look rents
fluctuate always throughout the country
throughout the throughout the world so
that everything four to eight so it
depends what's going on in the area so
obviously Aberdeen seen are a problem
because oil rigs in the oil industry is
dying up there anyway wise Middlesbrough
sort of struggle and you know apart from
the obvious but why is middle what's the
obvious
well it's Minister like I've been up
there a few times and I can't say it was
ever the most pleasant of experience it
just wasn't a pleasant experience was it
like hull it reminded me very much of
whole someone said say you say it on
holes nice but someone said that hold
was like the City of Culture say you say
nine holes nice it's really is it's nice
and I've got a hit Jamal's up there and
they're all rented out very well holds
good as an investment area I wouldn't
live there but it's good but I I there I
seen there no Hill whole city setting
was actually quite nice yeah I can't see
it have not really spent much time in
Musa but I've spent a lot of time in
hole that's the things I've got
properties up there I mean it was find
and I'm and renovating them a lot more
stuff so not as good but it's
interesting because obviously what
happens as rents go up then rents go up
so
more people want to buy their yeah so
then demand for properties goes up
demand
yeah house prices go up yeah it's a good
place to buy right now Nottingham Leeds
yeah it'd be interesting to find out why
they've gone up so much likewise noting
I'm suddenly a what's happening nor ting
on that suddenly pushed the rents up it
would be interesting to try and find out
maybe you can let us know what's going
on there must be some developments going
on or something I don't know and but
maybe there's a lot of investment
getting made into the area a lot of jobs
gone there but it's just watch out for
these these trades we can do a deal in
Darby okay building 25 apartments and
five shops right well she's not denying
you someone do faster if that's gonna go
up as well maybe both Darby SKU because
lots of industrial lots of their
factories in Darby you've got
rolls-royce there's lots of places in
Darby that really really good and yeah
Jackie Land Rovers up that make the
woods some Darby but it's more
Birmingham way I think it's running good
there's a plant in Wolverhampton but
there's lots of there's lots around
Darby but another interesting thing with
regards to like cities that are going up
is watch for these trades like obviously
if you know if you can work out why
they're going up then you can look at
once they're gonna happen and then look
at once I want to have it happen in next
three or four years and by now well
they're a little bit cheap and because
like developments like big multi-million
pound developments don't happen
overnight they're planned years and
years in advance so you can generally
tell where it's going was going up and
and if you take leads for instance
that's had a so much regeneration over
the last 10 years well you bent elites a
sent over last any any sort of time
recently I haven't mean for a while I
don't mean for a while too late do you
know the city center of the em it's the
what's it called remember there's a
really really nice city center there and
there's a really nice shopping center
it's massively been developed over the
last sort of ten years and that's why
prices are going up so yeah it's amazing
nice awesome right it's now time for
your questions and answers let's get
straight to it
[Music]
okay so we have some questions I've come
in from you guys thank you very much for
sending these questions in just so you
know you can send question on the
Facebook group or YouTube comments
Instagram comments anyway like just fire
the questions and we'll do our best to
answer them so the first question is
from Kabir Alistair lost weight have you
lost weight I have yes
what direct what due diligence would you
do with a joint d D so what DD for a JV
yeah so what DD would you do something
when you're doing a JV arrangement as we
discussed this error on the shores
really depends on like who I am where
what's got a charge in the property if
very much depend I'll make sure I was if
I was lending money I want to make sure
that I was protected I'll tell you one
thing I one thing if I was lending
somebody money I'd want to see their
credit report that's what that's my
little thing I'd want to see their
credit report because if they're not if
they're not paying the bills but if
you've got a charge on the property
why'd you care just I just do because it
tells me a lot about them it tells me
about their but if he's got the money
property it in a way it might even see
you if they didn't pay you back from a
financial point of view yeah but I still
if I'm gonna lay my money to somebody I
work incredibly hard for my money if I'm
gonna lay my money to somebody I'm not
gonna any money to enemy and they see
showed me the credit report it's that
simple that's one of my rules like
experience and experience just a copy of
the screenshot of the experience let's
have a look I want to see if they're up
to date with the bills and it's or not
then it doesn't sit well with me because
it means that they can't manage the
money and if they can't manage the money
how they going to manage the money that
I give them as an investment yes you
might have a first charge and a property
and you could get that back but I would
rather prevent prevent any problems
offset so really do your due diligence
only invest at least less you see you're
laying the money for somebody do your
due diligence from them do your due
diligence on their experience have they
got experience what training have you
done how many properties have got what
copies of the go and check the documents
make sure they are who they say they are
make sure they live where they say they
live make sure they're actually buying
the property in the pubs going to be in
their name or if it's in your name
you want to make sure you get drawn up
by solicitor yeah and that they look at
it and go look if the deal goes wrong
I'm I'm particular I'm protected or if
I'm not I know the risk that's what I
want yeah okay next question from corner
Arnold can you expand on bridging and
auction finance please can you just
explain what bridge in an auction
finances so it's the same thing
bridging and auction is pretty much the
same thing yeah so bridging is is
typically used if you if you if you want
to do some work to property you don't
want to get a mortgage because you're
going to want a mortgage it once the
works done you have a short term loan
usually 60% of the of the value of the
property and then quite often as a chunk
of if not all in some cases of the of
the refurb costs as well they'll lend
you the money they very much lend on the
on the deal rather than on the
individual so they want to charge in the
property they want to make sure that
they can get their money it's not what
we talked about a minute ago but yeah
they're gonna be doing their due
diligence on you essentially it's quite
expensive you're normally looking at
around about when I've done it in the
past used it a few times looking at
about 12 percent 14 percent interest
essentially bridging and it auction
finance are short term high interest
loans to enable you to purchase a
property quickly late you're a cash
buyer the generally the the the finance
is approved regarding the property more
you so it providing you're not bankrupt
providing you have any mortgage arrears
and providing you are there's one more
thing I think you've got be an electoral
rule or something but there's one more
thing that yeah there's not gonna say
very much anymore get it but yeah pretty
much anyone who get it as long as you're
not bank dropping in mortgage arrears
and got any outstanding finance issues
but then you'll want to get off it onto
a mortgage as fast as you can class
that's really expensive
okay so Ashley Harris top three tips for
securing Lease Option agreements start
off as a rent to rent yeah do you know
we talk at holiday and if you're
struggling to convert into to speak
something and convince them that a lease
option would work for them and offer
them a rent to rent forest with the
option to flip it to rent to a lease
option later so top three tips get out
start looking at properties find
properties that would match the criteria
for it so negative equity people that
are struggling to sale accept or excetra
and
a win-win it's got to be win-win make
sure that whatever you're given them is
win-win don't try and stitch anybody up
and exhaust the options give them every
other option before give them every get
yourself along to crash course we do
talk about this we talk about exhausting
the options making sure you you really
treat them like family
I advise them best with regards to rent
an out sale long it etcetra etcetra
etcetra and then if they still don't
really go for it and at least options
good for them
sit down blank sheet of paper and say
look what works for you what works for
me
how can we best come up to an
arrangement where we're both happy you
walk away happy I walk away happy end
off and then get it drafted legally best
Lazar I would definitely definitely was
a drunk contract
do not use a template contract it must
be drafted by solicitor if you want this
thing to stand up and especially when it
comes to purchase it in five or seven
years cool and get to the crash course
because there's training on it's
actually really really good
hey guys living the show Thank You
Victor is it possible to do an L away
rent to rent or rent to a in Scotland
sail away no rent rent yes then go Brad
Hart
what is the biggest hurdle you came
across when starting out interesting
Brad Brad the Hitman Hart well yeah
mustard ok biggest hurdle from me was
mindset and caring about what other
people thought I now have no problems
with mindset and I now don't give a rip
or people think so that was my biggest
hurdle
biggest hurdle is property on what else
we're not business I would say property
was convincing my wife that vesting in
property was a good idea ok yeah she
didn't she didn't like it at all shall
we do how many one more or two more
let's let's see how long this one is two
more two more two more hi lads
enjoy the podcast and I'm alright not
enjoy really enjoy get it right okay
cool
hi that's I thought I'd already read it
and that's what you stopped me enjoy the
podcast and again okay hi lad I'm really
enjoy the podcast like I really really
enjoy the podcast I've been listening
religiously for the last six months
would you consider a renter and
whether property is rented a student
accommodation from September to May and
went to the service connection via
Airbnb from June to August as a viable
strategy chairs yes absolutely
I stayed in a so I'm assuming in this
September to me it would be like sort of
HMO type rooms they let a lot in London
yeah a line I stayed in the hmm
Wolverhampton and that's what they do
during the term times its student and
off terms its its service accommodation
and it is a HMO it's got hitching more
doors it's got fire doors it's got
everything and it's like 25 pounds a
night yeah it was actually really good
but you cannot mix so you can't have
half heaps to half hitch you're more in
half service accommodation has to be one
or other what is that I don't know how
legal but I know that I've spoke to the
council's about it and they just don't
they don't they don't agree with it
whether that's legal I don't know but
either way I'd say all right final one
then Sharif Rashid hi guys absolutely
love the show tune in every week love
ank you
I love the banter and what not I wanted
to ask you have any tips on raising seed
capital for investments like deposit
money
I know lenders aren't keen on learning
it alone unless it's gifted but everyone
runs out of deposit money at some point
and where would we go to get this kind
of funding do you have you noticed it's
everyone I mention every week it just
seems to happen every week we pick a
topic we talk about it come in yeah
because you know we don't plan this we
literally we pick a topic beforehand we
film that face we fill in the face but
lives without the questions and then we
start filming the show then by the time
we come back to it half an hour later
they're all here so let's start the show
we talked about finding JV investors and
go back and watch that and and yeah
that's a good tip now with regards to
recycle and your cash maybe start
looking at the baby for which refinance
strategy you can refinance and get a lot
your money out so I'm doing a deal at
the minute we agreed yesterday that in
theory obviously will not know until
it's all done but in theory I should
pull all of my money out plus about five
thousand pounds
so great let me take about the gift I
know I know what you mean the key for
that I suppose really is is dealing with
a good mortgage broker yeah who can then
advise you because it very much depends
on the mortgage company what they wanted
but I know in the past people have said
to me well you might have to say that
it's it's it's a gift I've never had to
do that's we have to be super careful
because be careful how you raise your
deposits and and if you've raised it in
one way tell that be transparent with a
mortgage company although wise its
mortgage fraud and it can cause you a
problems down the line certainly be
transparent your broker and then they
can tell you how to word it how to make
a play yeah you want this you want to go
broke you've got a good relationship
with you can go to them and say look
this is a situation I've got this loan
30 grams coming in a mortgage how do i
best completely transparently lay your
cards on table - if this fits come from
this is how I've got it boom and then
they'll advise you correctly don't don't
ever try and hide where you've got a
deposit from because it would just come
back and bite you in the ass and it'll
it'll sting so there you go
well guys thanks for tuning in really a
bite you in the ass is sting we love no
no just it was a funny way to end it in
the ass on that not on that bombshell of
getting bitten in the ass and getting
stung in the ass that is the end of our
show tune in we're back here every
single Saturday at 7 p.m.
listen to us if you're driving on the
way to work do you know more more people
actually listen than watch I know if
you're watching this now you're you're
you're you're in the minority yes your
people are just hearing at you get the
privilege of getting to the guts -
handsome fellas maybe that's why a new
haircut it's a bit depressing most
people would rock there they kind of
want to help we go say but they can't
stand the idea of looking at us we've
got radio faces variety piece it's for
radio you're not a voice radio by the
way you fumbled that yeah see you next
week guys thank you guys
[Applause]
Oh